on this episode I talk about turning
points content real estate and chugging
you ask questions and I answer them this
is the askgaryvee show everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and welcome to episode
36 of the askgaryvee show fun fact about
the number 36 it's the last time I'm
doing a fun fact about a number Mary
asked Gary love to hear your opinion on
whether PR company or person should be
overseeing social media for a business
very great question and before I even
answer it I just want to thank you for
being a longtime interact or friend with
me I like using the word fan but I say
it sometimes it just slips Barry I've
always enjoyed our conversations on
Twitter over the last four years so
thrilled to have you on the show you
know I think I know where you're going
with this question which is the notion
of you know vaynermedia was built on
coming into companies and taking the
social media away from PR companies some
of the bigger PR companies in the world
right now have built out social media
departments and they've done a nice job
to varying degrees I wanted to answer
this question because I want to get
people around the psychology of the
difference between PR and social and why
I do think that of course there's people
look hundreds of people in this company
have worked in PR before so there's some
great things about PR being able to hang
a no-pressure
the speed of it the difference though is
PR is very b2b when you're a PR person
and you're working with a client the
Yankees you're trying to get them
pressed in the New York Times the New
York Post ESPN you're working directly
with a human being who's the gatekeeper
to make a decision when you're doing
social you're gearing with all the fans
and it's much more b2c so I don't have a
problem if a so ship a PR person or
company is doing the social for a
company or individual I just want to
make sure they have a different gear in
their brand understanding brain that
brand but that was interesting slip up I
just want to make sure they have that
gear to know that they need to be
looking at this as a b2c game versus
big B game that is PR East County today
says Gary love the iTunes touch what was
the moment you knew you would be okay
when starting your company
he's County right
you can't East County it's a little bone
thugs reference to episode can't
remember ah this county the moment I
knew that I was going to make it was the
the first day I walked into my dad's
liquor store and and the reason I
decided to answer this question and
trying to find value for everybody
watching other than me bragging about
that I had the bravado from day one was
the notion of not even worrying about
that moment meaning one of the biggest
things that I'm trying to teach I know
I'm turning a lot today one of the
things I'm trying to teach all my
management here at vaynermedia and all
my founders in in my startup investments
and my co-founders in companies that
have meeting with my co-founders at resi
last night the number one thing I keep
telling everybody is to not worry about
the things that don't matter
worrying about or trying to figure out
this is the moment when I made it is
something that I think cripples people
and I just don't even think about those
things I could answer this question two
ways which are the two right ways which
is one the moment I walked into my dad's
store because I had that confidence or I
could answer the other way that's
equally is true pulling on both sides
like a bridge which is I haven't made it
yet they both are right and the truth is
outside of this question I don't think
about it at all ever period and the
reason I'm answering the question is
because I'm trying to get as many of you
who are watching this show right now to
not worry about those things worried
about executing worrying about feeling
good about your life don't worry about
making it because making it is an
outside force the inside force of you
just doing it is what you should be
focused on Kyle ask Gary is there a way
to drive traffic to a website when
posting content directly to Facebook
Kyle yes as you can tell that Facebook
post on my fanpage drove a crapload of
traffic to my medium article which is
content Facebook you know I answered
this question because I wanted to show
you raw details because I think raw
details is even a deeper version of this
show and I continued to try to go deep
within myself to really drive you value
especially because this is only a 50
episode experiment just kidding
uh and so the answer is absolutely
Facebook is actually probably one of the
biggest drivers of content awareness
outside of itself to other destinations
in the world right now so the question
is how do you do it organically how do
you do it in a paid targeted wait what I
just showed you was organic I have a
pretty big foundation of 150,000 fans on
that page but there's people that I've
seen post content that have 800 fans and
the enough people shared it and enough
people you know liked it enough people
commented it and shared it not only
within Facebook but outside of it
that it created fire Facebook is is
content awareness infrastructure in a
2015 world so not only is there a way I
think it's one of these singular best
ways and so I would highly recommend
making an investment in facebook
fanpages recognizing the you know
distribution opportunities that it
creates for content you're putting
outside of its network hey Gary I'm a
realtor and our team puts out a lot of
video today you said it was important to
put out daily content so my question to
you is if you are realtor what kind of
daily video content would you produce so
that was a tremendous video let's all at
the vaynernation pay attention to
multiple things including he was wearing
the ROI of your mother t-shirt the fact
the ding the jab jab jab in the
background at random man walked by in
the background which is reference to
some of the stuff we've done in the show
if you're listening on the podcast I
highly recommend you go to youtube and
watch this episode just to watch this
video because it was tremendous my
answer is very simple if I was a realtor
the thing that I would do more
and anything is actually review the area
around the places where I sell homes let
me explain if I'm selling homes in
Millburn New Jersey I'm putting out a
daily piece of content reviewing the
school then I'm interviewing the
individual teachers if I can get access
to them then I'm reviewing every local
business the subway shop the wine shop
that I'm interviewing literally people
that have lived in the neighborhood for
50 years I'm putting out content to make
you romantic around the stories in the
area because people pick them for
utility convenient what I mean by that
is convenience of transportation how
quickly from the office but they also
pick because of the school systems and
there's a lot of data out there on that
but how about making it a little warmer
and interviewing Miss Robinson the
third-grade teacher and then obviously
kind of the amenities around it right
the playground you know the best stores
I remember realtor telling me that
people move to Short Hills because of
Wine Library I thought that was cool
felt like such an anchor to that area
and so what I would do is daily content
on the 20 mile radius or 10 mile radius
around the area where you sell the homes
the stories that are tucked away in the
businesses and the school system and the
iconic neighbors that have been around
forever those stories are the narrative
that will create a motion which will be
on a tipping point scale on a 50/50 may
be the thing that tips someone to buying
your home
Shawna Gehry most big successes have a
huge turning point where things really
take off what was that turning point for
Wine Library Shawn great question you
know I guess there was some turning
points when you know the Wine Spectator
ad that we ran the first New York Times
full-page ad the time I reset the store
and took 50% of the beer off the floor
and added more wine when I started Wine
Library calm the day I started the email
service the dot the dad jumped in to
Robert Parker's forums in 97 and became
part of the internet community around
wine you know the 2000 Bordeaux vintage
when we bought heavy when I first
started promoting wines and nobody ever
heard of an email richard partridge
Cabernet comes to mind when I hired
Brandon as you can tell there are many
moments that we made it but it was just
trucking along building
on top of each other step by step my
friends if you listen to two of my
answers on this show you understand one
very interesting thing about me which is
I may have the energy of the hair but I
am The Tortoise you know what I'm
putting up there right that beautiful
thing you did sag show Zach did a very
nice job on that one ah for everybody
listening I'm pointing to the tortoise
and hare image I put out an Instagram go
check me out on instagram / gary vee
anyway ah when I made it the turning
point moment everybody who's watching
and asking these questions are looking
for this sign like I saw the sign like
like this sign that like okay it's not
that it's head down you love it and
believe in what you do and you just
never think about those moments you just
keep trucking along it's lunch pail
mentality it's old-school Eastern
European put in the work mentality you
know I don't think about these things
guys the fortune 40 under 40 that just
happened is that a turning point of my
career sure some people now think of me
differently because I'm in the context
of those people but it's not it's just
chug and chug and chug and chug and chug
and chug and chug and chug and so chug
thanks for watching the show you like
that the Iraq don't edit that part I
want your giggle in it thanks for
watching the show everybody episode 36
in the bag question of the day so choose
this whole theme of the show question of
the day very simply uh do you think
you're a chugger
or do you think that you had a
turning-point moment and if it was what
I what was that and by the way episode
35 we dropped off of the momentum of
episode 34 on the banter I've told you
about the banter I can't be this
situation where I have to yell at you
about banter and then it happens and
then you fall off the next episode I
expected maybe 15 episodes and I'd have
to talk about banter again but the
community get in the comments get in the
comments thank you you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
oh crap wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe